cette norme il est temps maintenant pour
nous d'écouter la voix de la nation
française en colère le courroux
nationale le procureur général de la
république des proches française
[Musique]
monsieur le président monsieur le rigolo
cinématographique qui monte qui monte
mesdames et messieurs les jurés public
chéri quand l'accusé daniel auteuil
s'est marié il était débordé il appelle
temps de partir en voyage de noces aussi
exceptionnellement je demanderai à la
cour de le laisser partir en voyage de
noces après quoi nous le guirauton
guillotine robien sur daniel voulait
nous rappeler pourquoi m'avez pas pu
partir en voyage demain sauf que j'étais
retenu pour le hic pour le doublage d'un
poste saint canut synchronisation du
film de marguerite duras le camion oui
vous faisait les essieux cinéma
malheureusement au chaud plus ce film
j'ai réussi le brûler alors nous allons
parler du voyage de noces moment
privilégié dans l'union du couple le
voyage de noces reste dieu merci
l'une de nos trop rares vieille coutume
qui ait survécu à la barbarie moderniste
de ce siècle déshumanisé par
l'uniformisation des rapports humains
les cadences infernales l'éducation
sexuelle au laser et les vibromasseurs à
quartz
c'est pourquoi les jeunes mariés moderne
se doivent de respecter ce rite
doucement sur année en apparence mais
dans les conséquences psychosociologique
bénéfique sur l'avenir du couple sont
inestimables au départ afin de mettre
toutes les chances de notre côté pour
que notre voyage de noces soit un succès
total sur le plan touristique
sentimentale et sexuelle
la première chose à faire est de partir
seul en effet en effet sur ce point les
plus grands spécialistes mondiaux des
problèmes du couple sont d'accord il est
indispensable pour assurer la pérennité
et la réussite d'un mariage que chacun
des deux époux ça se garder un jardin
secret un petit coin de vie autonome ou
l'autre n'a pas accès afin d'éviter le
dangereux piège de l'habitude ou sans
sable à tout jamais trop d'idylle
conjugale pourtant bien commencé sous le
double signe de la tendresse et des
guili guili tout papier or il n'est
jamais trop tôt pour lutter contre les
mauvaises habitudes
c'est pourquoi en vérité je vous le
redis partait tout seul en voyage de
noces ce conseil vaut évidemment autant
pour les poupe pour la jeune mariée
encore qu'à la réflexion on peut se
demander ce qui est raisonnablement
faire une jeune femme seule à venise
avec toute cette vaisselle qui
s'accumulent à paris ou à vierzon mais
paris c'est encore pire car si plus loin
de venise que vient son c'est une
excellente question je vous remercie de
me l'être
oser
et j'aime répond aussi sec halte-là mon
garçon au point de misogynie je dis mon
garçon parce que quand je suis tout seul
j'avoue qu'il m'arrive de m'appeler mon
garçon d'autres fois je m'appelle ma
fille mais ça m'excite je peux pas
non point de misogynie le plus simple
pour savoir lequel du mari ou de la
femme va partir pour le voyage de noces
net ils pointent deux tirés au sort si
bon alors si le sort désigne le mari il
aura le bon goût de ne pas marquer une
allégresse excessive au moment de
demander à ces jeunes femmes de préparer
sa valise
surtout s'il s'agit d'une jeune femme
hyper sensible ou violemment haut de
gamme si le sort désigne les pouces
on procédera à un deuxième tirage au
sort si le deuxième tirage au sort
désigne les pouces on procédera à un
troisième tirage au sort et si le
troisième tirage au sort désigne les
pouces pourquoi après tout ne partiriez
vous pas avec elles elles en meurent
dans vie le moment idéal pour un voyage
de noces à venise c'est
incontestablement le mois d'avril
6 pourquoi personnellement je me suis
marié en décembre je déteste venise il
faut faire des kilomètres pour trouver
un flipper d'autre part on nous dit que
c'est une ville chargée de souvenirs
mais en fait c'est plein d' impasse où
circulent des mongolienne et de lacunes
ou veufs des monts gollier
le plus célèbre de tous et montpellier
le plus célèbre de tous ces maux gaulier
s'appelle totori alto c'est un doux
crétins une offensive qui vit dans une
vieille barque a soudain pour vénitien
où il passe le plus clair de son temps à
ricaner sottement chaque fois qu'il
surprend un jeune couple tendrement
enlacés tous les amoureux du monde
connaisse bientôt rialto puisque ce sont
eux qui l'ont surnommé si judicieusement
le conte des soupirs il est il est très
difficile il est très difficile pour ne
pas dire impossible de trouver à venise
un bon restaurant
j'ai oublié le nom du soi-disant en
meilleurs restaurants vénitien
d'ailleurs c'est un nom italien
imprononçable je me souviens seulement
de l'air ahuri du maître d'hôtel quand
je vais demander un simple puis jette
beaujolpif est un phare breton donc les
vénitiens sont xénophobes
on ne compte plus les déboires des
touristes français à venise récemment
les joueurs de l'as ptt de romorantin
ont clairement discerner des regards
hostiles parmi la population vénitienne
alors qu'il dispute à une bien
inoffensive partie de football dans le
palais des doges en nocturne
quant au club des joyeux chasseurs
solognot ils ont eu récemment le plus
grand mal obliger un épicier vénitien
rétifs à leur vendre une boîte de petits
pois destinés à accompagner une
trentaine de pigeons qui leur
appartenaient pourtant de droit
puisqu'il les avait tués eux mêmes à la
boule au cours d'une partie de pétanque
sur la place sa main
dieu merci venise n'est pas que cela
comme le disait si gentiment heinrich
himmler en visitant auschwitz eux sous
la pluie
ne boudons pas notre plaisir venise
venise reste malgré tout ne l'oublions
jamais l'une des villes les plus
extraordinairement pittoresque du monde
avec ses 90 église ces ensembles
architecturaux magnifique et lagrasse
tranquille de ces innombrables canaux où
s'étire tofield et printemps toujours
recommencée les amours tranquille de
tous les enfants du monde
et puis surtout ne l'oublions pas à
venise on reçoit très bien antenne 2
combien de jeunes couples légitimement
déçu par les attraits sur fait de cette
cité prétentieuse et plein de [ __ ] ont
retrouvé la joie de vivre à l'hôtel
gabrielli dont la plupart des chambres
sont équipées de téléviseurs
quoi de plus exaltant pour toi tendre
épouse et est pour toi juvénile poulain
fou que d'être interrompue au milieu
d'une banale fornication conjugal par la
belle tête constante de jacques chancel
ainsi yehudi menuhin vous
et moi mais là il faut voir la scène
ainsi il dit mais nous ils vous avez
tenu à venir avec vos amis de leur
caisse nationale de chambre de vierzon
et de la chorale somnifères rick davies
coincé dépassant 14 rue des sarcelles de
chair pour une interprétation du final
chanté de neuvième symphonie de wolfgang
amadeus que shell your dream in win
accompagné par le pianiste japonais
roberto banzaï après quoi après quoi le
professeur makowsky président de
l'association des médecins qui font de
la télé pendant les heures de
consultation nous parlera de son
séminaire de travail à venise etc etc
dans une prochaine émission nous
aborderons ensemble si vous le voulez
bien le problème du voyage de noces à 3
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
etonnant non